[Music]
yeah thank you very much
for the
invitation also from me it's been a
great
meeting nice interaction
so i'm going to talk about longitudinal
and phenotypes and and disease
trajectories and
the motivation is illustrated here
published we published the reviews a few
years ago
about sort of disease progression
and the problem in going uh bottom up
from our mix data to to disease
phenotypes i mean generally in general
is especially for for
common disease um
it's not
easy to go from the from the variance so
other armic states are up to what kind
of comorbidities uh
and and actual longitudinal phenotype
you you you get do you progress fast or
slow and and all that because
nobody had really tried to map
in a population wide way how does it
actually look here also at this meeting
we've just seen comorbidity statistics
that's sort of just
frequencies and not uh so much about
which disease travel with what other
disease and in which order uh for
example if you if you get um
sleep apnea before diabetes
then the mortality is quite a bit
different from if you get the diseases
the other way around so the order
matters a lot in disease progression
pattern so so we uh we went into this
idea
of taking uh population-wide data from
from denmark
trying to find out what what are the
frequent patterns what are the highways
in in
in disease space we start out reasonably
clean many of us but then we get
diseases and of course this whole
journey here
life cause
disease development it's influenced by
germline genetics but also of course
exposures
primarily drugs but of course also diet
and a ton of other things but things but
but how does it look like when you look
at data from millions of patients and
this is what we've been working on for
the past 10 years so in denmark we are
sort of having
a good situation i mean we have
i mean i wouldn't say the patient
records are perfect but there may be
less messy than than many other places
but we have hundreds of registries
that go way back and we got our
social security number i'd identify the
identification on by 1968 so we can link
everything that that happens over these
long periods of time so in the danish
national patient registry for example
we're forced in more than 40 years of
data with the prescription registry here
we have have have
more than 25 years of data but hundreds
of other registries some large some
small but they
in many cases
tend to be population
wide and then of course also genetic
data is is um
can be added and linked if you have a
permission uh to to to all these uh data
and now we got a new law actually in
denmark for for a new
genome center agency that is picking up
genome data from healthcare
and the law says so all this you can
skip but here it says a single national
database for stories
so by law if you become sequenced and
consent to becoming whole genome
sequence or exome sequence at
a hospital
you will have to have your data going
into this database you can actually opt
out of having the data used for research
um
but uh but that is not very common
denmark that that that people opt out of
most things it's sort of based on on
on that principle you're in if you're
not opting out
so so the national genome center and you
see the crown from the queen here i mean
this is states
uh
agency that that holds the data for
for the entire uh country and this is
also well known that i mean denmark is
one of the most if not the most
digitized country in in the world
there's very little paper uh left so we
can sort of use we're a small country so
still small uh we will we will be out
competed by by large uh countries but um
but so far we have at least data maybe
from from at least 10 million people so
when we started doing this 10 years ago
this is from the first paper
we
look at the diagnosis in the icd-10
system that we used since 1984 and you
see for inpatient outpatients and
emergency room patients and females here
and males you see as a function of age
you see all the pregnancy related to
diagnosis that you're not seeing here
injuries chapter 19 you see it here that
you have more for the for the males and
i normally also point that at the cancer
the brown chapter you can see kicks in
earlier for females than than for males
due to breast cancer so this is
essentially seven million individual
trajectories so so um we made an
approach to try to condense that into
the most frequent patterns that then can
be hold up against the genetic data and
other army states and actually as i said
we can go more than 40 years back so so
in 94 we switched from a icd-8 to icd-9
and i will also show you one example
where we use the 40-year data and fan
quest cancer a little bit later and
actually we go further back because the
death registry is from 43 so we also
have a paper cooking on on how the
development in the death registry is is
looking uh like but the the original
approach was quite simple you
essentially take core current diseases
and you see whether they have a
statistically significant direction will
more go from a to b than from b to a and
you can make a fischer's exact test and
you can do that in in more advanced ways
but that was the basic idea and you form
linear trajectories and then you can
summarize them as a graph where there
are some alternative roots and you can
for example use the thickness of the
arrow to indicate how many patients we
have so the idea is not to say sort of
case control
for for one diagnosis versus the rest
but we want to sort of split patients
into groups according to the
longitudinal pattern this figure is from
a paper on on sepsis we made a few years
ago that i still use i mean here the
thickness of the arrow
is the relative risk in relation to
being dead 30 days after you get your
sepsis diagnosis
so coming from down here
mental and behavioral disorders is worse
than having cardiology problems and and
so on and actually what prompted us to
to to do this analysis was that
certain papers said that diabetes would
increase your risk of dying from sepsis
and other papers said the opposite but
actually if you sort of put the the
patients into three three longitudinal
sort of subgroups then we could
rationalize all the relative risks we're
not going into details with it but that
but that's the um that's the idea so we
made a ton of of deceased trajectory
analysis papers here's depression here's
absolute epilepsy so what we're working
on
currently
and and this is of course the aim for
many people is sort of to take the past
and predict the future
and and um
and machine learning algorithms are sort
of preferred model for for that one
example from a few years ago with
intensive care data
we sort of tried to see could we predict
mortality
from the disease trajectory of so this
is sort of an n equal to one
set up where you take a decision
directory from one patient and then you
also take data from the first 24 hours
here
after admission sort of the acute data
physiology data lab values and so on
this is 15 years this is 24 hours so we
call it aggregation of of of time scales
and the big question is of course is it
easier to predict after 24 hours from
the acute data or or can the disease
trajectory data out compete the compute
the the the acute data and it's
illustrated here if we take one of these
sub two scores
and also the apaches go i mean the the
performance is lower than if we take the
history at admission
so actually already when we roll the bed
into the ward
we can predict the mortality better from
the disease history
than we can can after 24 hours you
during the using the vitals and the lab
stations but of course putting it
together together is even better so
aggregation of time scales in in in a
setup like this
kind of is completely general of course
and can be used in many other contexts
and you can look into the paper about
how how we look at interactions i mean
age is of course important for survival
and intensive care but if you have
metastatic cancer so there's an
interaction between
a 35 year old with metastatic cancer
will still have a high probability of
not surviving the the icu estate but a
lot of details in that in a follow-up
paper we used not an old-school
perceptron but an lstm network and made
sort of a dynamic prediction every hour
and then we sharp explain the network
every hour so that we can rank up and
down the factors that draw the patient
towards
death and and survival and that that can
then inform the physician about what you
should uh work on
in uh in a more recent paper that is not
published yet we work with with the
centers group in boston on on pancreatic
cancer because this is really a tricky
case
where the disease comes a little bit out
of the blue
not a lot of risk factors that are known
weight loss diabetes a few other things
but you're pretty healthy
of you you remember steve jobs for
example uh not super sick before he he
got the disease so so what can we do for
this kind of of of of of disease so you
see pancreatic cancer is discovered very
late
and um here we we use some more modern
machine learning deep learning
approaches but also we try to replicate
danish model on data from from mass gen
brigham
and um you see in in not surprisingly we
have
longer disease history in in in denmark
we use the 40-year data and in boston
the data set was smaller we also had
more more more cases and and and here we
use the more advanced deep learning
scheme with embeddings where the time
between the diagnosis in in the first
play was just the order
but nothing about the time here we
actually also take the time stamp
into account
one problem that we ran into
um
uh that gave us some some issues with
with the replication is like that that
you just skip all these numbers here but
if you look over here for the danish
data and here is the number of disease
codes we have per patient
you see for the cancer patients and for
the no cancer patients we have sort of
quite limited number of diagnoses but if
you go to the us data
they code like crazy
and of course there is a billing uh
buyer's reason for that uh maybe one uh
diagnosis in europe is 10 diagnosis in
the u.s
so it's not necessarily worse i mean it
might give more money
to the health care provider but it could
actually be that the us data with this
way of sort of fine-grained coding if
the if the coding is okay is actually
not that bad so i'm not saying that the
danish data is better than the american
data it's just difficult to take a more
coarse grain coating and make a
predictor and then use it on on on the
boston data and there's some number here
where we we do fairly well on danish
data and when we predict on danish data
uh but when we do the cross application
it's it's it's not so
so so effective we're working on that
with other
us data sets now and and
and we are
soon finished with with the revision
so one interesting things about thing
about uh disease trajectory is also that
that we in many cases have mixed
ideologies
for example the way diabetes is coded is
sort of maybe a few codes for something
that represent many different
mechanistic
ways of getting diabetes
and this is from a paper we published
that i will not go through where we
actually claim that two-thirds of the
patients they actually have two
ideologies running
and not just one so so everybody wants
to to put patients in disjunct groups
but it's not always so easy because you
can get at least on the surface the same
symptoms and the same sort of sort of
presentation by by different methods
so um so we've been looking into that um
and and dementia has been one case of
course you can also get dementia in
various ways you can have alzheimer you
can have
have a
vascular dimension of course also
pneumonia here but we worked on on on
this and this was motivated by this
statistics you see here that very often
and i would think it's the same in most
other countries that that you
that you have a lot of unspecific
unspecific diagnosis because the workup
has not been completed
many more than you would have from from
from those with a clear alzheimer's
diagnosis or vascular dementia diagnosis
and
so we we said okay we fixed this problem
by
by looking at the disease trajectories
for alzheimer's here we have alzheimer
and then you see what leads up
to it
and here you see vascular dimension a
little bit more rich but it's many of
the same diagnosis
and actually turned out that no matter
what we do
did we couldn't really separate the
patients
many details that i just leave out
because i just want to touch on this
theme of mixed idiologies we had so many
patients so that we could take just
patients exactly being 80 years
taking many confounding factors out of
the equation with pollution and whatnot
here they are 70 here they are 59 to 61.
but you see we can separate down here 40
to 50 but but that's essentially because
of down syndrome patients that that have
early onset dementia and they're easier
to spot from it from the disease
trajectory so this was unsuccessful we
still got it published in a
decent
impact factor 19.
journal because the conclusion was then
that many more patients
should maybe be assigned sort of a mixed
dementia
diagnosis we didn't know really about
mixed dementia diagnosis but then we
learned that in icd-11 that comes up
this has now been implemented and there
are several mixed ideology codes around
dementia so it was a success in this way
that we actually couldn't discriminate
between the patients because too many
patients presumably have
um two diseases running that that that
give them the same kind of problems with
with with memory
and
you might say i'm not so interested in
all these danish data but you can
actually
use them yourself we made a browser
where you can plug decision codes in and
then you can see how it looks like in
the danish data if you for example take
the lupus situation you could try to
plug lupus in here and then you can see
how the the the decision progression
looks in lupus and in dangerous states
all this is just summary level data
there's no person-sensitive data but but
it's based on these 7.2 this is a newer
version of the method and you can
increase the relative risk and then you
go out some of these links and you can
manipulate these trajectories and and
also put them into two to papers that's
also a way of making health data
available in a secure way that you boil
it down to the summary level statistics
and then plug it into a tool and then
and we also
doing that for example for the for the
death registry now we make a death
trajectory browser that presumably will
scare certain people here if you for
example take down syndrome and plug and
then you will see that it picks up the
correlation to alzheimer's
very very well
so in a newer paper we have done the
same with prescriptions
and um
same idea so go a little bit fast same
patient group
we have linked to all the gb
prescription 1.1 billion prescriptions
in what order do you get your drugs
and
so this was 24 years of
data and then here we have of course
talking drugs and not diagnosis
and i still use color so i sort of
recycle the the colors here so so now we
are talking atc
group colors for the different drugs and
you can make statistics again for
for
females and and males and you see that
there are some differences for example
with nc contraceptives and so on so this
is sort of to to be expected but again
this is 7.2
individual prescription trajectories how
can we boil them
down and this is what this paper
is about
and uh what is interesting of course in
in precision medicine is with if you can
predict whether a drug is the right drug
for for that particular patient
and the one thing is that you can see
how patients go across all these uh
different htc groups maybe not so
interesting but you can for example zoom
in on one chapter and you could look for
example at hypertensive hypertension
blocks
and and there you have first line
treatment and second line treatment and
third line
treatment first line is normally ace
inhibitors and then you switch to arb
blockers it doesn't work too too well
and so you can follow these groups and
you can compare them and you can also
look at their mortality this is sort of
a simple survival analysis but if you
take those who stay on ace and those who
stay on arb and those who shift you can
try to compare them in terms of
mortality and then of course you can
also use them as groups groups in them
in in the g was and we have also uh done
that if we look at the same
data i mean these are large numbers
because we have seven million people in
in in the data set
but if we go to uk biobank we are we are
down at smaller numbers because this is
500 000 but the same kind of
of of of ranking so so we think we can
use these
prescription
trajectories a little bit in the same
way we haven't really done it
yet but we think we can maybe spot
the patients who who should uh shift
earlier
and it's quite interesting i didn't say
for the for these disease trajectory
projects we also have genetic data in
some cases and and for example we have a
project on ischemic heart disease it
doesn't help much
to to add the genetic data to the
to the disease trajectory because you
you should remember that that genetic
data is germline risk but if you have
this sort of 40-year disease trajectory
then you have the realized
uh risk that sort of includes the
exposures in some way so it's hard for
the for the germline genetic risk to to
uh to compete with that and i think also
these prescription trajectories they
reflect many of the drug
shifts that you get into
uh where ross oldman would be able to
tell us that
that this shift is because you're having
this variant and therefore you should
have
this uh dosage of warfarin and not not
uh some some some other things but but
that's the idea so just to to finish
up i mean i haven't talked much about
omix data but let's just show you a few
slides from from a project that we work
on where we have just submitted the
revision
um my main point here was to say that we
need the phenotypic side of the equation
when we would like to interpret our
mixtapes that we need to get it into a
more
longitudinal fashion because what we
call a disease today is something that
actually stemmed from the icd system
that was started in 1893
so so of course the icd-11 system it
seems to be pretty detailed and quite
interesting in many ways reflecting a
lot of
experience
but it is not a mechanistic model of
of of disease like for example peter
robinson has suggested in a short paper
new england journal that i also can can
recommend
but here we we work in this direct
project european type 2 diabetes project
with newly diagnosed
type 2 diabetes patients not so many
close to 800 where we have mulching or
mixed data
so not
so much disease history here but very
deep in terms of our mix
and we use an autoencoder to try to
understand this data
but the idea here in this project is for
example to see
can we predict what is the multi-omics
and there's also been other talks at
this meeting what is the multi-omics
impact of giving a patient one drug
versus another
and
and of course when we shift the drug
then the reconstruction of that data
will also change
and the reconstruction was surprisingly
good a lot of details that i i skipped
on on on this
project but when we looked at the latent
variables i mean
here we use this masuda index that sort
of quantifies the insulin sensitivity
the um the autoencoder has really
understood that there is a continuum in
diabetes it's not just type 1 type 2 and
type 3 there is a continuum
because of these different
mechanisms and remember this is
completely unsupervised we're not we're
not plugging anything
in here and when we look at the raw data
we get very little uh signal so we tried
to sort of give the patients who didn't
get a particular drug uh that particular
drug
and so in some sense they learn these
patients not getting the drug they learn
from those who actually got the drug and
where we have the impact on on on the
omics data right and
what comes out of this compared to
traditional statistics is many more
drug omics associations and also you see
the different blocks down here
for for traditional statistics we this
group of patients mainly get um
associations for the two statins here
and then for metformin
uh but but but when we look at that
at all the other drugs these patients
get we get we also pick up associations
there i will combine this with a patient
approach also
so we cut a little bit down on the
associations but this is the the idea if
you for example see what is the
correlation between the drugs can we
have drugs here and clinical features
here if we for example take the um the
statins the two statins here and see
which clinical
features do they change the most and
then it's fasting ldl and cholesterol so
i mean there's sense in it if we go to
to metformin it's blood glucose hpa1c
and other glucose measurements so so we
think this kind of structure can be used
to make um
get dunking experiments i mean they
often say in in healthcare that you
cannot make the control experiment
of finding out what would have happened
if you have chosen another treatment of
course you can say you give the patient
this and say it doesn't work we take an
artwork
but you cannot know what would have
happened if you have done it in the uh
in the opposite
order and we think this kind of of
machine learning approaches with
genomics data potentially could could
allow us to to mechanistically say
something about and this was also a
theme yesterday what what the
what what impact would this job uh this
drug have on this particular patient
given this this this cohort and a lot of
details and in that and and here we
tested drugs we also have diet
information we could have used many
other things and made these these
matrices
on but uh
but but but this is also where we try to
go with some of these multi-omics uh
data sets and try to make them into
something that actually can be used as
as tools in in healthcare so just to sum
up um
what i'm trying to tell you
is that i think we should not just stay
with the traditional diagnosis we should
put them into a longitudinal form and in
some sense we should treat a trajectory
and not just uh a code and and send the
the payer a a bill that that's the um
idea and we think also the trajectories
might be more predictable in many cases
than the single diagnosis also because
of this mixed egology
problem and
so this is sort of very sparse i've
mainly
been talking about the diagnosis and and
prescriptions but of course you can you
can work on on many other
socioeconomic data you also talked about
socio-economic data uh yesterday and of
course there's a lot of
impact here
compliance is a huge problem in
healthcare do the patient actually
do the patients take the drug or not i
mean there's a lot of noise in these
data
where we can use socioeconomic data
actually to take those
noise sources out of the equation to
some extent so that the chance of
getting a mechanistic signal is is
higher so it's not because i'm super
interested in education and grades and
exams but in denmark we can actually
link to your grades in your high school
exam
so we can compare people who have high
grades in math versus low grade grades
and math and see whether it has an
appearing on on some of these things so
it's very rich and and linkable one of
our current project is to work on smart
meter data i guess many of you have a
meter in your home
that
tells you something about
your electricity consumption and and you
can for example use that to compute
whether people likely or the household
likely will get up early in the morning
or late so so some of these phenotypes
will also come from from some of these
socio-economic data and
so um maybe the final slide if i have
the time that i also often point at i
mean
we still have
many genes in the human genome that that
are really not assigned a
function
and um
this also came out of this illuminating
the dragonball genome project that that
i
pointed at a few days
ago and and and here's the time and
here's the number of genes people
thought the human genome contained
actually if you go back to 1960 people
thought we had seven million genes
because that was before introns were
discovered so so human genes were the
same length as as bacterial genes but
now we know it's twenty thousand so it's
also clear that the pathways are much
more disentangled than we ever uh would
have imagined uh
actually it was a dane who invented the
word gene and there the idea was that it
was one trait
but actually i'm sure
one gene is involved in a ton of
diseases and that makes it also
difficult to assign function and that's
yet another motivation for actually
studying in at a population wide scale
how the decisions develop
so thank you to my group and to to
collaborators and they are
some of them i'd be happy to answer
questions and thank you again for coming
this early
[Applause]
thank you
questions
maybe i can start
in terms of the
[Music]
trajectories do you see difference in
the quality of ability to
to infer from this data between types of
diseases because i would imagine for
example that mental diseases would be
much more difficult to you know to
follow than
others that that's a good point and
i mean last year we published a paper on
on over diagnosis and under diagnosis in
in copd
because i haven't included it in this
talk here but but we look at for example
copd patients who have their diagnosis
in a very unusual context
say why are they so unusual
they it looks like they have their
diagnosis
in in a way that's very
dissimilar to to most copd patients
and it's in npga digital uh
medicine and and
so we then checked the
patient record and many of these
patients did not have good spirometry
tests
and uh
and what made it into a paper was that
this group
uh with this copd diagnosis they um
they died much faster then you should
think if you have a diagnosis you
shouldn't have you should live longer
but
but this paper
sort of presents the idea that that here
there are some patients which are over
diagnosed for copd but it turns out that
they are under diagnosed presumably for
lung cancer that that is untreated
hence they die faster so so we should
use our bioinformatics sort of mindset
to clean up data and we think we can
actually spot these unusual ones that
might represent errors made in in the
clinic and not to blame anybody because
they have a busy
day but i think we can use some of our
techniques at least to either it's nice
or super interesting because
it's a diagnosis you get in a very
unusual context
it's a result of a follow-up so
are you able to assess the effect of the
changes of diagnosis criteria like there
are some diseases that will change how
they are diagnosed yeah across time
yeah
and i do not have a good
example
because
our under diagnosis paper and copd is
not
um published but that's that is an
example where they changed diagnostic
criteria and where we looked into it and
tried to track
how did that change the the frequency
and the context of the diagnosis so
so it's also something that is super
relevant to go into
maybe one last question we'll keep the
rest for the break
thank you so much um
i'm curious about
undiagnosed mendelian disease patients
so
um we've we've been working with
vanderbilt's phenotype risk-scoring
algos and to your point about claims
data
they would say because everything above
50 in the us healthcare system
is get gets billed you can actually read
off
from how people create through the
healthcare system for example in
undiagnosed cystic fibrosis patients
which there are it's certainly in the
united states 25 30 percent may be under
diagnosed
80 of fh patients are not diagnosed we
just ran this in andorra and identified
patients with um
uh down syndrome you know most of the
patients down syndrome actually didn't
have a diagnosis in the hr so i'm
curious about whether you've done that
kind of replication work and what the
numbers are for the danes yeah i mean we
we've done a little bit of it it has
mostly been in in rare skin diseases
because our
medical school happened to get a
skin center
uh each oriented and and so we went a
little bit into it but but please
suggest some examples and then and
there's also the browser but of course
again the browser
might be problematic because i've mostly
talked about level three of icd and many
of these vertices they would be level
four and there we have to do them a
little bit more handmade so we need to
interact and and mail about because
and also a population um
that is
would have 200 million people
would allow you to spot more
and we worked with andrew rezky actually
in a paper where we
pulled the danish and the american days
and that would also be able to happen
okay thanks again
rosie